to what extent do you think
that everyone can be an entrepreneur
versus is it like like I guess what what
sort of traits should someone have if
they're thinking of starting their own
business someone recently described
entrepreneurship to me as a game of con
constant
reframing and I think I agree with them
because more stuff gets thrown at you in
entrepreneurship than in anything else
so like clients come clients go team
members do you you you're probably
putting out many fires every single day
but all of it is a game of how can I be
okay with this fire that's taking that's
taking place around me and how can I
just get better at putting the fires out
but then dealing with bigger fires after
that so um I think it develops a mental
toughness that not everyone realizes
comes with it and I feel like you have
to be ready for it but once you're ready
for it it's really
good